entre piano projet de loi qui a été
déposé le projet de loi 64 qui permettra
de serrer la vis aux entreprises qui
détiennent des renseignements personnels
l'objectif c'est de mieux protéger les
québécois ont parlé avec sonia lebel lé
ministre de la justice ministre
responsable des institutions
démocratiques la réforme électorale et
de l'accès à l'information
on vous retrouve à saint-hilaire bonsoir
madame lebel bonsoir je vais présenter
un projet de loi aujourd'hui on veut
vraiment mieux protéger les données
personnelles des québécois qu'est ce
qu'on va faire concrètement on va agir
sur trois pôles si je peux dire de cette
façon là donc on va donner plus de
contrôle aux citoyens sur leurs données
personnelles le renseignement donc on va
donner les exigences de consentement
très clair très distincts pour chacun
des renseignements usages vont investir
et on augmente la responsabilisation des
entreprises on leur donne l'obligation
de se doter de règles de gouvernance de
politique de confidentialité d'intégrer
les meilleures les meilleurs systèmes de
protection à la conception même de
dollars de leur entreprise ou du service
qui pourrait offrir aux citoyens ça se
voit surtout dans les dents les avancées
technologiques ce genre de situation là
et de l'autre côté en contrebas pour
contrebalancer tout seul dissuader les
entreprises qui seraient peut-être
tentés de ne pas se conformer vont
augmenter de façon considérable les
sentences le de l'ordre de 25 millions
de dollars 4 % du chiffre d'affaires
mondial de ces entreprises on sait
guider ont été conseillés coller à
coller sur les meilleures pratiques se
passe maintenant en europe a que le rpt
et le règlement général dé protection
des données et salue donc la peur des
sanctions similaires c'est ça madame
legault les montants sont similaires
absolument absolument absolument n'ont
rien inventé le successeur du cadre
régulier de ce qu'on fait ici ce qu'ils
avaient avant qu'ils étaient plus de
l'ordre de 50 mille dollars à peu près
mais si on s'est collé on n'a pas serré
ça d'un chapeau le prix ce qui se
faisait en europe et c'est le tout c'est
d'avoir un effet dissuasif parce qu'il
faut comprendre que dans le secteur des
renseignements personnels
particulièrement c'est une donnée qui
est très lucrative pour les entreprises
et liste de dates restent mais le poumon
profilage économique pour être capable
de m'envoyer des cibles et on le voit
sur facebook instagram entre autres
c'est pas dans le voyeur également donc
c'est une donnée qui est très lucrative
c'est un marché qui est lucratif donc on
peut
on peut le comprendre le citoyen des
fois avantage est ce que cette donnée
loi soit soit transiger mais il faut que
ça se fasse avec son consentement et
avec sa connaissance et si c'est pour
faire de façon sécuritaire les amendes
seront rendus c'est important de faire
la distinction madame lebaye l'on parle
pas ici d'un serment de code de fraude
de vol de données personnelles
on pense à des jardins évidemment quand
on pense à des données personnelles
c'est plutôt là la commercialisation le
fait que nous données personnelles
valent quelque chose sur le marché c'est
ça ou et tu te fais faut faire la part
des choses c'est sûr que l'on pourrait
penser que dans que si une entreprise
des meilleurs standards de sécurité de
protection de nous donner ça donne moins
d'actifs est un fraudeur qui voudraient
les volets de c'est sûr que tout est
dans tout le vécu avec les politiques de
cybersécurité aussi sont autre chose
mais effectivement on parle vraiment des
splendeurs de protection le consentement
de transactions avec nos données d'avoir
d'informer le citoyen de la mobilité de
s'adonner de lui demander son
consentement avec l'avant de faire
donner aux citoyens le droit aussi de
dire à une compagnie écoutez moi je suis
d'accord vous allez détruire mes données
ou du dos de demander une compagnie quel
type de données de renseignements
personnels vous avez recueillis sur moi
avec usage d'une application son autre
téléphone à titre d'exemple c'est ce qui
frappe le plus imaginaires donc le droit
le droit l'effacement donc le droit de
dire à une compagnie moi mon contrat
avec vous est terminée vous avez vous
allez soin de détruire mes données
personnelles ou les anonymiser donc pour
des fins statistiques ce serait correct
ans qu'on peut pas m'identifier ou
murray tracé donc c'est vraiment on est
vraiment dans l'encadrement de la
gestion de la saine gouvernance de nos
données personnelles s'assurer que le
rapport avec les entreprises privées se
fait de façon consensuelle avec le
consommateur
vous avez vous commencé mais non le mot
consentement vous savez comment ça
fonctionne mal d'amis rebelles on change
quelque chose on nous prévient mais le
formulaire est souvent extrêmement longs
ont défait les oncles et j'accepte sans
trop avoir compris est ce qu'on pourra
s'assurer que ce sera simple
compréhensible de faveur à quoi on
confond mais il s'est fait ça fait
partie de la notion de consentement
éclairé et vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est dans un langage extrêmement
pointus juridique effectivement soit on
se tait nal avant la fin de la lecture
et vous avez raison qu'ils acceptent et
on clique j'accepte souvent sur
consentement très générale de
l'utilisation sans qu'on nous explique
je pense que vous avez dû remarquer com
- comme d'autres de nos concitoyens que
depuis quelques temps depuis quelques
mois mène on voit apparaître qu'on
appelle des consentements plus distincts
et les fameux coups qui n'ont pour nous
explique avec quand on clique pour plus
de détails on ben on nous donne la
possibilité de désactiver certaines
fonctions ou de consentir à un usage non
pas un autre genre la géolocalisation
qui pourrait se faire avec une
application nous disait dit d'accord
pour la géolocalisation oui ou non donc
on a déjà commencé à voir apparaître
parce que ça fait déjà deux en europe et
dans certains états américains apportent
au canada on est le chef de file mais ça
se fait déjà en europe et dans sa thèse
d'état américain de ces entreprises qui
sont à l'international surtout on voit
déjà apparaître conformité l'a donc
plusieurs de nos entreprises ou seamine
au québec vont recommencer à avoir venir
le vent si je peux m'exprimer ici à
s'adapter
on le voit de plus en plus ce sera une
question d'adaptation effectivement pour
être capable de consentir anti encore
faut-il comprendre à quoi on conseille
c'est la clé de ce consentement éclairé
le oui est là avec ce projet de loi on
exige beaucoup d entreprises qu'elles
aient de meilleures pratiques mais
encore faut-il pas seulement se fier à
leur bonne foi là qui va s'assurer que
les entreprises font ce qu'il faut là
que c'est la commission d'accès à
l'information la caille qui aura des
pouvoirs de surveillance et pouvoir de
rendre les ordonnances des pouvoirs de
faire des demandes péremptoire donc de
vérification qui vont qui vont lui être
attribué
il y aura des des demandes de reddition
de comptes mais des réductions dans le
sens de l' usage des renseignements
personnels l'orienta de tenir des
registres de bris de confidentialité il
ne s'est pas tous les buts pris oui les
drêches de confidentialité qui m'irrite
nécessairement qu'on s'y attarde
ça peut être minime majeur mais chaque
mode rush de confidentialité ou devra
être à la disposition de la caille
lacaille devrait être formé par le biais
d'un registre
bon alors rions dans un mécanisme de
surveillance y aura un suivi
je vous remercie beaucoup madame lebaye
l'on s'arrête là dessus ça fait plaisir
merci bonne soirée avant